no somos modelos somos barrenderas de
todo
haremos todo para que el medio ambiente
sea agradable y el aire que respiramos
no nos provoque enfermedades
estamos arreglando el país para que el
país esté limpio
estamos orgullosas de nuestro trabajo
gracias
[Música]
Esto no se había visto nunca una ovación
en pie para las barrenderas del Omega
para su décimo aniversario el fimo
Festival Internacional de la moda de
togo ha elegido destacar aquellos de los
que nunca se habla los primeros en
luchar de frente Por la protección del
medio ambiente el gran tema de esta
edición 2023
[Aplausos]
en nuestro equipo tenemos 15 días de
trabajo y 15 días de descanso
somos las mujeres barrenderas que
mantenemos nuestro país limpio
y son solo mujeres nada más que mujeres
Pero por qué no hay hombres
nuestro trabajo no requiere hombres solo
mujeres Pero por qué
las mujeres son voluntarias porque el
trabajo de los hombres es diferente al
nuestro
los chicos cortan las flores el césped
esa es su parte
[Música]
Jack luego fundador del festival está
muy implicado en la vida social de lome
creó el fimo cuando sólo tenía 25 años
también Es estilista y lleva cinco años
desarrollando su propia marca
Exacto Exacto porque también tengo que
tener mi propia línea de ropa
funciona todo el año y mantener la
industria de la moda que es lo que suelo
hacer
en 10 años Jack Jojo a desarrollado el
festival que se ha enriquecido con
clases magistrales porque la moda es
negocio creación y comunicación
[Música]
para esta décima edición del festival
hemos elaborado un programa Muy
atractivo un programa muy cargado de
hecho nos pusimos en contacto con
artistas visuales
contactamos con artistas visuales porque
el tema es la protección del medio
ambiente y el reciclaje
[Música]
esta exposición se ti la tercera vida
Esto significa que se ha dado una
tercera vida materiales ya en uso y
estamos haciendo un programa de
entrevistas con maquilladores y de
maquillajes porque en la industria de la
moda hoy en día no se puede hacer moda
sin recurrir a los maquilladores
luego están los fotógrafos Porque
después de un desfile de moda las
imágenes tienen que ser bellas
las imágenes tienen que ser nítidas
invitamos a fotógrafos profesionales
versados en el campo de la moda
son la esos fotógrafos están allí para
entrenar y formar a estos jóvenes
fotógrafos que también quieren
profesionalizar su carrera en la moda
para mí tomar una imagen es como
colorear me dan una página en blanco
para colorear intento colorear a mi
manera así que para mí es importante la
imagen
significa contar una historia
la historia que quiero contar es que la
vida es bella y no hay que cambiar las
cosas son como uno las ve solo hay que
dejar que se vean Así que los fotógrafos
la pasaron en grande contando las
historias de los diseñadores que idearon
su propia visión personal del reciclaje
como estas esponjas metálicas
me gusta reutilizar cosas porque creo
que más que las esponjas es el hecho de
que están en peligro de extinción sobre
todo desde que otros empezaron a dejar
de usarlas a pesar de que limpiaban
nuestras ollas y sartenes pero no elegí
Hacer una limpieza de los camerinos a
través de esto
[Música]
Así que se trata siempre de reciclar
reciclajes siempre así que hice un poco
de blindinas y también recibí los globos
de plástico con los que jugábamos de
pequeño Porque estos globos como están
hechos de plástico con productos
químicos Una vez que se estropean los
niños los tiran a la calle y me dije
recupero estos globos para mostrar a la
gente que estos globos También tienen
efectos nocivos para nuestro medio
ambiente y nuestra tierra
pero la ropa la ropa existe y es ropa de
verdad o es eso
sí son prendas reales y solo quería
Añadir ese toque de globos para
concientizar
Cuál es la historia de hoy
cuando me mudé a todo descubrí que no
podía hacerme ropa nueva porque todo se
ha convertido en el botadero de la moda
rápida
y también nos llegan toneladas de ropa
usada de oriente muchos zaris indios
Así que la reciclamos y las convertimos
en prendas ponibles que nos encantaron
fue un proceso muy creativo en el que
participaron artesanos locales para
crear nuevas piezas
la idea era pequeñas tiras de esos
viejos saris y tunearlas
espero que la gente los haga suyos y los
ame aún más
los desfiles No han terminado la noche
será larga especialmente para ellas las
heroínas del día las barrenderas de lome
[Música]